[Music]
what's going on guys
Wonder Woman critically acclaimed and
dominated the box office so what does
that mean going forward we're going to
talk about that today with what's next
for Wonder Woman and we have a wonderful
panel hon boom to talk about it with
first she's the founder of geek bombs
welcome Margaret thank you I'm excited
to be here he's an old friend of the
show emphasis on old he's right he's the
writer of Batman 66 meets Wonder Woman
welcome back Marc and Rico thanks for
having me Helen can't wait to talk about
this movie heck yeah
and she's the host of TV fights and one
of the co-hosts of the tomorrow show
Roxy stryer welcome to screen junkies
thanks for having me on the show of
course so you guys first off what we
think of the movie I've seen it five
times so I hated it no I love it it's
just a glorious movie it's a really
great pizza but it's also incredibly
nutritious it feels low the closest one
obviously what is it like I said it's
like watching Raiders of the Lost Ark
the first time I've never cried in a
sequence before and in these fight
scenes and wail slo-mo and all these big
amazing things that are happening I got
very emotional what did you connect to
as you're watching that this is a time
when we saw probably the most females
I've ever seen in a fight sequence
before we saw that they paid so much
love and attention to detail with these
sequences the way they slow it down it
was so empowering
I completely agree and I cried also
during the first training scenes because
I don't think it can be emphasized
enough how we have never had no I've
never had that I've never looked at a
screen and had it be a bunch of kick
butt women all flippin off of horses
throwing their daggers into the ground
and I couldn't even believe how much I
was missing that before I actually got
to see it how important was this movie
for the DC EU I mean it was probably the
make-or-break yeah I think more than the
box office I think the reviews are what
makes what was making one of others
executives really happy today
because this is not only the best of the
DC movies this is arguably one of the
best superhero movies ever made yeah
there was so much pressure on this movie
that I feel like people almost were
setting it up to
and the fact that the reviews are as
strong as they are it does everything
for the DCE you moving forward it means
that people are excited for justice Lee
just because Wonder Woman is in it and
thinking about the next time we see
Wonder Woman on screen in her own film
where do we want to go with Wonder 1
what we want to see or do I hope they
don't keep revisiting the Greek
mythology well like they did with
Superman with Kryptonians I want it
contemporary I want it to lean into
being a superhero movie I want to
cheetah you know how great would Charlie
be a cheetah how great would Angelina
Jolie be is dr. Barbara Minerva I want
Giganta let's unpack a couple those
characters tell us about cheetah she's
all rage and anger and animalistic
that's where Wonder Woman is peace and
love sure so it's she's she's basically
Wonder Woman's Joker in a lot of ways
she that other than Ares cheetah is
Wonder Woman's big enemy so I just heard
from every single person it's got to be
cheetah on top of the fact that Charlize
would be amazing and people want to see
that patio and Charlize team up again
everybody wants it and a female villain
though unlike dr. psycho who I actually
would love to see Peter Dinklage
yeah this here's my throne in the second
movie that would be an oh my god so have
I satisfied both of those here we go we
get the talkative psycho 2 Peter
Dinklage side of things but we enter
Veronica kale as basically she's kind of
like the Lex Luthor of Superman so she's
all about science is all about you know
studies you've got a pharmaceutical
company she's a villain Yeah right right
all that drugs but to you the doctor
psychos to manipulate situations and to
turn the tides on Wonder Woman you hit
the nail on the head talking about
Veronica Kael being of the Lex Luthor
because Lex Luthor and Superman and
Veronica Kalin Wonder Woman is kind of
like Salieri to Wonder Woman
Mozart where we're a Wonder Woman and
Superman are just this this is who they
are and Lex Luthor and Veronica Kael
have to work really hard for the success
we've never seen two women who are
equals fighting it's always about a boy
or about their being manipulated by a
man and having Veronica tail be the one
that's moving the chess pieces they only
like a dude nah what do you think about
Medusa again I swear playing into this
hole we've got two women especially with
each other and you know I think the gold
on mythology is like phenomenal it's fun
another thing that's interesting though
is because Aries tells us he has taken
out all of the other
odd it's tricky sing daddy enough Kenan
I use a very different tracking things
sure bumper hey yeah well he could be
lying
we don't know he's also a lot he's
potentially lying about her origin story
so he might be lying about this as well
I'm gonna throw some other names of
potential villains I'm a sheet is top of
the list
you guys have named some great ones
including Medusa what about seriously
the sorceress I say back away from Circe
just like Game of Thrones run its course
first before you start mixing that up
yeah the same thing is in this day and
age an issue of people are going to oh
they're just ripping off Game of Thrones
people don't know anything about history
no joke no joke I know that like we're
saying in a joking manner but seriously
no get confused what about the circle
lobby's the circle were Gail Simone's
run I believe it was for Amazons who
were supposed to kill baby Diana the
only problem with that is I would I like
the Amazons being kind of an idyllic
society by having Amazon - or traitors
who are manipulated a kind of no matter
how well it's done the subtext of that
is once again a group of women sort of
eating their own we can have women
outside that you can have a cheetah or a
Veronica kale kind of like this the full
horseman we kind of sold that with X and
apocalypse and it's like if you have
another fall coming on the beasts board
would do something I don't think you can
I don't think we can do that
contemporarily though because what were
they doing all this time yeah what about
Artemis once again it's the footage the
circle again it's another Amazon it
takes up the mantle Artemis in the comic
book took over for Wonder Woman when she
lost the mantle and you can in your
second movie have your character with a
mental you know way and people were so
upset when Wonder Woman lost it yeah we
are not touching that I don't think that
I agree makes total sense so I feel like
Vegas odds right now are heavily on
cheetah yeah I've heard a lot you guys
are going to cringe in my toes but about
eggs whoo coming back no there is no way
a bright yellow Chinese egg is going to
be made into a movie larger no joke ever
an outcry on Twitter people being like
this is what needs to happen I'm very
confused by it but I just wanted to
throw it out there then people are
rooting for it let's look forward in
another way
how much does Wonder Woman legitimize
the prospect of female superheroes
getting their own standalone fills so
Elektra definitely didn't do it yeah
catwoman Linden do it super girl
definitely didn't do it Wonder Woman
finally we've got something right now
those movies did not fail because they
had a female lead those movie fails for
many other reasons but people have used
that against it for so long now you no
longer can say a movie with a female
superhero will not make money it's great
because it's going to open the door for
a lot of these weak female lead projects
to be greenlit but it also sets the bar
really really I mean there's gonna be a
lot of conversations at Marvel and
Disney now about how do we keep up
because Marvel didn't make Deadpool or
Morgan or Wonder Woman but they played
the groundwork to enable those movies so
they need to like step up their game two
things that we discovered from patty
Jenkins with this one is it hopefully
from the suit in the future no longer
will it be a risk to hire a female
director and the second thing that we
found out from this is that when DC the
Warner Brothers Studio steps back and
lets the director make a movie good
things can happen the thing that's also
really fascinating about patty on this
movie is she didn't decide to make a
Wonder Woman as a career move she made
this movie because she loves this movie
just as much as she loved making monster
so higher I don't care what the gender
or the race or the creative director
hire directors who are passionate about
these projects and love the characters
and want to make character driven
entertainment thank you for taking us on
a deep dive of Wonder Woman where she
might go and what it means for the DCE
you and filmmaking in general what did
you think of Wonder Woman and who do you
think she should take on next where
should she go let us know in the
comments section below you want to know
I want to thank Maude Garrett mark and
Rico and Roxy stryer for coming in and
breaking it down for us
fun conversation I want to thank you for
watching I'm how Rudnick's hit me up on
Twitter I like
[Music]